it's it's changed my life tremendously
the one interesting story the first time
I went to Russia I had sort of i had an
MCI mail account but I didn't use it
much there weren't very many people to
send email to and it was really
unpleasant to use so I went to Russia
met all these interesting people and
discovered that it was impossible to
stay in touch with them by telephone
because the telephone system was so bad
whereas email you just send the mail and
it might take a day or two to go through
but it would get through so I started
using email to stay in touch with the
people I'd met in Russia so that in a
sense the existence of the Internet
enabled me to stay in touch with people
which therefore made the travel more
worthwhile and in my personal case it
vastly increased my travel because it
you take a trip and it kind of adds
value to the trip by enabling you to
maintain the contact after the trip and
then so you go make another trip and so
forth so that's one very specific way a
second and of course these all are very
broad but I'm trying to be concrete the
second was I began my career as a fact
checker in Forbes and I used to go to
the Forbes library which is this huge
cavernous place full of file drawers and
file folders and you find probably a two
year old annual report two or three
faxed press releases and maybe a
clipping or two about any given company
and that was all you had to go on so
then you would try and figure out the
phone number for the PR got you to call
the PR guy and then you'd get a big
packet of the last year's annual report
in the nail along with more press
releases and then you just had to call
around and find sources there was it was
actually really hard to do research and
now it's just amazing you you go go go
when you find it all out
find the bad stuff and the good stuff in
the untrue stuff so the the availability
of information is just astonishing
compared to what it was like and the
speed with which you can get it all this
has changed dramatically in my own life
I used to remember phone numbers just in
my head and now now I don't anymore
mostly because I don't even call people
but if I do they'll be in my cell phone
and most of what i do is by email and
then i'll use email to set up
appointments in a sense i'm now a lone
operator it makes it possible for an
individual to do things that previously
were possible only to an institution you
can communicate with people directly you
don't need secretaries and all this
infrastructure you can outsource a lot
of stuff your banking all this kind of
thing so it's as I mentioned earlier the
erosion of the power of the
establishment of the institution in
favor of empowering the individual I
still so short of time but the amount
that i can get done these days is
astonishing
in politics the politicians haven't
recognized this yet but they're
beginning to that they're really two
things one is the increased transparency
and I'm on the board of an organization
called the sunlight foundation which is
trying to trying to even leverage that
tendency and first get Congress people
to become more transparent and if
they're not simply to use the kinds of
research methods i mentioned to find
stuff out what real estate transactions
happen next door to them all this stuff
it's also changing people's expectations
they expect answers they they want to
find the answers to their questions if
they have a problem they expect some
response and so people are beginning to
expect two-way communication rather than
simply listening to the candidate
speaking and the broadcasting
you